Dr. Cutters, what do you know about C60 for mitochondrial health?
I have heard that it raises formal levels and it's safe for breast cancer.
It does seem that when I take your greens first by tumor bleeds more, it doesn't cause the blood to be thinner.
So the answer to this one first, the greens first can cause it because it doesn't have a lot of different herbs in it.
So if that's the case, I would just stop that greens first or just cut your dose right down.
The C60, I'm not a super big fan on increasing mitochondrial function with cancer patients because you could also increase the mitochondrial function of the cancer cell itself.
So the mitochondria is the organelle within the cell that you make energy.
That's the main function of the mitochondria that also has some DNA components in it.
But the main function of the mitochondria as we know it today is to make ATP.
And ATP is what runs the cell and runs all your cells.
And you know, increasing mitochondrial health and cancer patients is often thrown upon in the alternative community because you are also increasing mitochondrial health in cancer cells.
That's at least one light of thought. Remember with dealing with cancer, there's there's often multiple lines of thought.
Just like you know, my light of thought is not to use a lot of high amounts of glutamine when you have cancer because like question earlier, because it could increase growth. That's the whole idea of glutamine.
But there's other alternative doctors that do that that use glutamine. It's so it's just, you know, you have to, you know, do your best research and kind of trust your gut on some of these things too, but I am, you know, I've studied C60.
A number of years ago when it first came out, there's a book had some information about it. I got the book.
I just felt like that was the right thing to do with cancer.